und ich begrüße ganz herzlich professor
and wohlmann er ist der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der fdp
professorin so viele neue infektionen
wie noch nie in diesen tagen warum jetzt
die regeln entschärfen und dieses risiko
eingehen wir haben es gerade gehört
ausgerechnet jetzt
wir schärfen keine regeln geschaffen
eine rechtsgrundlage die auch
rechtssicher ist und wir haben hier eine
quantitative veränderung in zum vorteil
der qualitativen veränderung der
maßnahmen geführt denn viel denn wir
haben feststellen müssen dass wir für
den kommenden winter sicherlich
gegenüber corona nicht winterfest sind
und dann können natürlich auch viele
maßnahmen dazu aber professor kollmann
der maßnahmenkatalog ist ja jetzt
beschränkt wenn der nicht ausreicht was
dann gibt es einen plan b einen plan c
wenn diese maßnahmen nicht ausreichen
die maßnahmen die wir im
infektionsschutzgesetz sehen sind der
versuch physikalische barrieren
aufzubauen die auch richtig sind und wir
haben ja auch gerade in dem einspieler
gehört dass die verhältnismäßigkeit
gewährt sein muss und auch gerichte
haben in der vergangenheit auch diese
lockdown maßnahmen ja auch gekippt wir
setzen uns dafür ein also wir als
zukünftiger ampel das hier maßnahmen
ergriffen werden die regional auch
angewendet werden können so zum beispiel
das 2g und 3g aber machen wir uns nichts
vor nichts vor denn diese maßregel
alleine wird die korona pandemie nicht
stoppen wir müssen hier dramatisch
massiver die impfung voranbringen denn
wenn wir dann schauen dass die besonders
bühne rahden und älteren menschen ihre
impfschutz medizinisch kaum noch haben
die sich medizinisch nicht mehr
vollständig geimpft gehen kann es nur
dann sein wenn sie die dritte impfung
erhalten haben und auch viele menschen
auch ab 18 die an johnson johnson
impfstoff erhalten habe haben ebenfalls
keinen vollständigen impfschutz und
bedürfen auch da eine musterung diese
informationen müssen heraus und auch
laut ausgeschrieben werden und dann auch
maßnahmen ergriffen damit mehr geimpft
wird weil impfung ist die der weg aus
dieser pandemie etwas entsprechender
gleichen auch lassen sie uns noch mal
bei 2g 3g
sie sind ja sehr skeptisch was die 2g
regel angeht sprechen von pseudo
sicherheit weil ja auch geimpfte das
virus weitergeben können das
naheliegendste wäre dann doch in dieser
situation auch geimpfte müssen sich
wieder regelmäßig testen
das wäre eine sehr sinnvolle maßnahme
gerade in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen denn wer geimpft ist kann
tatsächlich noch eine infektion bekommen
und dann natürlich auch infektiös sein
die schwere der erkrankung wird nicht
passieren also zumindest 90 prozent der
fälle wird dieses nicht passieren das
macht durchaus sinn meine skepsis
gegenüber ob soldo sicherheit gegenüber
zweig war darauf gemünzt das nur zweig
alleine nichts bringen wird ich sehe es
durchaus auch als sinnvoll an zweig
maßnahmen hoch incidents bereichen auch
einzusetzen und auch durchaus auch in
variablen bereichen wie pflegeheimen und
auch krankenhäuser aber hier muss man
klar sagen testen ist sogar noch viel
besser deswegen haben wir auch die
testungen in den schulen haben wir auch
die möglichkeit das ist was wir auch
voranbringen wollen das war auch ein
sehr schlechte idee die kostenlosen
bürger teste einzustellen die wollen wir
auch als ampel wieder einführen und 2g
könnte ja auch dazu führen dass sich
wieder mehr menschen impfen lassen sehen
wir in sachsen oder auch in österreich
da bilden sich inzwischen wieder
schlangen zum impfen das ist doch
eigentlich der effekt den sie sich auch
wünschen oder ja absolut ich möchte
gerne haben dass die menschen sich
impfen das ist längst überfällig aber
sachsen wie aber auch bayern muss
dringend aufholen es gibt andere
musterländer in deutschland ich sag
jetzt mal freistaat bremen das natürlich
eine stadt ist das was anderes als in
ländlichen regionen aber auch schleswig
holstein hat eine sehr gute durchimpfung
auch die booster impfung laufen
hervorragend in schleswig holstein das
sind musterbeispiele wie es eigentlich
bundesweit nicht funktionieren sollte
und das ist eigentlich schade dass auch
in meiner heimat in bayern dass sie noch
nicht durchgeführt wurde also die
künftigen möglichen ampelkoalition ehren
wollen heute über mehr tempo für die
korona impfung beraten dazu ist heute
ein fachgespräch mit experten geplant
aber was erhoffen sie sich davon also es
gibt ja auch hier diese forsa-studie die
umfrage die zeigt die große mehrheit der
ungeimpften will sich auch künftig nicht
impfen lassen wie wollen sie die denn
jetzt überzeugen das hat ja auch schon
die vergangene regierung getan oder
versucht zu tun
die noch amtierende regierung hat
versagt in meinen augen in der
kommunikationspolitik
aufklärung fand kaum statt ein pixum
sind alle gerettet reicht nicht aus als
aussage sondern wir müssen verstehen wie
die warum die impfskepsis vorhanden ist
und diese entsprechend begegnen durch
information gezielte information und
machen wir uns auch nichts vor es gibt
auch durchaus sprachbarrieren die jetzt
angegangen werden muss wir müssen auch
die impfungen zu den menschen bringen
ich erlebe es ja auch meine eigenen
heimatstadt in würzburg wo mobile in
teams unterwegs sind das jetzt sehr
gerne angenommen und ich bin immer noch
erstaunt wie viele leute noch ihre erste
impfung jetzt erhalten da müssen wir
mehr machen auf der kommunalen ebene ich
bin selber ja stadtrat und weiß das wie
das funktionieren kann und dabei darf es
auch eine lokale engagement diese
menschen zu erreichen die sich bisher
noch nicht impfen ließen denn ich wurde
hol mich immer wieder hier die impfung
die booster impfung ist etwas wo wir
dann wieder weihnachten feiern können
aber wenn wir es jetzt zu laufen lassen
und warten was passiert dann wird
weihnachten schwierig werden aber
deshalb haben wir als zukünftige
potenziellen ampeln koalitionäre ein
gesetz auf den weg gebracht das wird
sicherlich auch noch mal nachgeschärft
weil wir am montag eine anhörung haben
und dann werden natürlich experten noch
vorschläge unterbreiten und ich glaube
sicher zu sagen dass wir auch offen sind
für weitere gute und gesetzes und
verhältnissen gesetzestreue und
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen nächster
woche sollte auch eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geben die
fdp ist bei so einem bund länder treffen
dann ja gar nicht mit dabei bei den
grünen immerhin winfried kretschmann
wenn wir jetzt auf die korona zukunft
mit einer einer möglichen ampelkoalition
schauen wäre denn da nicht auch ein
anderes format denkbar oder auch
sinnvoll
ich denke dass ein
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
etwas sinnvolles ist im austausch aber
das hat ja in der vergangenheit leider
nie so funktioniert wir haben ja
wahrnehmen müssen das hieß ja immer in
ich haben wir einheitliche regeln und
dann wurde schon die regeln verändert in
den einzelnen bundesländern es ist gut
wenn wir jetzt ein regelwerk auf den weg
bringen für ganz deutschland das
regional auch anwendung finden kann das
ist der weg wie wir vernünftig
vorangehen dass auch
gerichtsfest ist und auch
parlamentarisch eine große mehrheit
findet das ist der weg neben der impfung
aus dieser krise zu kommen
sagt professor an trollmann vielen dank
für dieses gespräch ich danke ihnen